foreign
Thompson are two best friends who are
working on some Ai and ml projects this
is when Mark has a doubt and he wants to
build up a publication and he's just
wondering which AI tool to use this is
when his friend Thomas suggests him why
don't you use chat GPT he says charge
GPT can help create websites by
generating necessary code Snippets and
giving various recommendations to speed
up the development process
now Mark thinks that he has been
thinking lately a lot about chat GPT and
how it has impacted our lives and Thomas
wonders well it isn't great right so it
provides our answers for everything that
we want to work on this is where Mark
says to his friend that he wants to
explore some Alternatives other than
chat GPT so Thomas also becomes curious
and he wants uh to know what are some
other Alternatives and he says charge if
it is impressive but it's always good to
explore other options as well
on that note hello everyone welcome to
Simply learn you've probably heard all
the buzz about chat GPT lately it's
everywhere from social media to the news
High performing air chatbots are a
reality thanks to open air GPT this
chatbot's goal is to have conversational
interactions with users as a result this
technology has completely taken over the
Internet also it has some millions of
users there have been some problems with
this chatbot well it's not perfect
sometimes charge GPT might generate
responses that are factually incorrect
or nonsensical it's because it's
essentially trained on patterns and
doesn't possess Real World Knowledge so
it's important to verify the information
it provides especially when
chargeability is overloaded and users
are unable to access it so it's
important to explore the alternatives to
charge GPT and in today's tutorial we'll
go through some of the best charge gbd
Alternatives but before we begin if
you're new to the channel and haven't
subscribed already friends are getting
subscribed to our Channel simply learn
to stay updated with all the realistic
content
now before we move ahead and discuss
some various alternatives to charge gbt
let us understand what chat GPD is
exactly about now charge GPT is a
powerful language model developed by
open AI that can be used for a variety
of natural language processing tasks for
example answering questions charge gbt
can provide information and answer
questions on a wide range of topics
including general knowledge science
technology history geography and much
more
writing assistance and content
generation charging Beauty can generate
text in various Styles such as news
articles product descriptions social
media posts Etc it can provide
suggestions and help with creative
writing tasks it can also generate ideas
offer writing prompts a system
storytelling or provide feedback on
written content
and finally coding support charge GPT
can be a boon for coders it can help
programmers by generating code Snippets
explaining program Concepts or providing
guidance on coding related issues as
well
let us now understand why we use chat
GPT chatbots have been a source of
interest for decades but majority of
them are still very unsophisticated
which are not capable of answering
complex queries on customer support or
resolving the issues of dissatisfied
customers however the world of NLP is
progressively approaching a new chapter
with charges capacity to carry a
discussion through several questions and
generate software codes so let us
understand what are the use cases of
charge gbt now natural language
understanding which is one of the most
important and significant use case of
chat GPT where it is has the ability to
understand and generate human-like text
responses making it easier for users to
interact with the model in a
conversational manner its accessibility
and versatility charge GPT is accessible
to anyone with an internet connection it
can be used for a wide range of tasks it
can answer questions provide
explanations of a suggestions help with
creative writing translate language and
much more it's what versatility makes it
appealing for both individual users and
businesses continuous learning language
models like charge GPT can be
continuously improved and updated by
training them on large amounts of data
as more data becomes available the
model's performance can be enhanced
leading to more accurate and useful
responses over time and finally
Community engagement openai has actively
engaged with the developer community and
the public encouraging feedback hosting
competitions and releasing tools and
resources to enhance the usability of
this language model this open and
collaborative approach has fostered a
Vibrant Community of users and
contributors further fueling the
popularity of charging Beauty nowadays
now comes the main question how chargpt
Works chargpt generates responses to the
text input using a method called
Transformer architecture
now what does that mean now a large
volume of text is ready to charge GPD
from various sources including books
websites and other social media
platforms the model then uses this
information to forecast the following
word in a phrase based on the words that
came before it the chat GPT system
allows user to enter text or queries and
then the system uses its training data
and algorithms to produce the right
answer
how does it work let us now understand
some of the limitations of charge GPT
now firstly we have the contextual
understanding of the uh machine learning
model which is charge GPT May struggle
to understand the context of a
conversation leading to our responses
that are sometimes irrelevant or
non-sensical it may not accurately
interpret a Nuance or complex queries
requiring users to provide more explicit
context
next we have lack of Common Sense
reasoning now chargeable does not
possess inherent Common Sense knowledge
which can result in responses that are
technically correct but may lack real
world applicability it may provide
answers that mean that seem plausible
but are not practical or accurate in a
given situation
bias responses one of the major drawback
of GPT is By Us in responses chargedical
inadvertently reflect biases present in
its training data if the training data
contains biased or unrepresentative
examples the model May generate
responses that perpetuate or increase
those biases so care should be taken to
identify and address these bias related
issues
now having this limitations things as
whether we have any alternatives other
than charge GPT well we do have a lot of
alternatives to charge GPT this is where
we have the Google bar on the first of
our list these days Google is all in on
AI and Google bad is its Flagship
product it's an AI chatbot and it's very
much meant to be a rival to the ever
popular chat GPT just like charge jpd
googlebot is a conversational AI chat
bot where you can ask it any question as
long as it does not violate its content
policies but will provide an answer for
you although Bud hasn't officially
replaced Google Assistant it's a far
more powerful AI assistant that's
because it's based on Google's own llm
large language model also known as
Lambda which is language model for
dialogue application now just like open
AI chat gpds 3 the model behind charge
GPT the engineers at Google have trained
Lambda on hundreds of billions of
parameters letting the AI learn natural
language on its own now the result is a
chatbot that can answer any question in
surprisingly natural and conversational
language which can create a more natural
and human-like interaction between users
and conversational AI systems allowing
for more sophisticated and nuanced
dialogues some of its features includes
it provides real-time information now
unlike charge EBT provides only
real-time information until September
2021 in some of the cases whereas Bart
can give you all the information at
current times as well now it also has
voice to text input speech also improved
task automation where Google can now
better comprehend the intent behind a
search query with the aid of part and
give more accurate and relevant results
and it also has some of the more
advanced coding abilities than chat GPT
now second on the list we have chat
Sonic now Chad Sonic is an AI power chat
bot platform from right zoning
organization that enables the users to
utilize ai's pass to personalize their
content now a sophisticated machine
learning model based on neural networks
is combined with a script dialog in
order to simulate human speech chatsonic
is used for text and image creation and
it has a powerful connection with Google
search that helps to come up with Hyper
relevant content additionally it can
generate any kind of content be it blog
post emails tweets posts product
descriptions
Etc chatonic is a powerful AI chatbot
that uses the latest natural language
processing technology to answer
questions accurately and informately if
you look at this snippet I have asked
chatsonic what is the difference between
chatsonic and chargeability and it gives
a comprehensive answer to this question
so it is easy to use reliable and secure
making it a great choice for businesses
looking to automate customer service
interactions
next on the list we have Jasper AA
Jasper is an AI powered platform that
provides personalized Voice assistance
and automation for businesses it uses
NLP and machine learning to understand
and respond to customer queries and
automate routine tasks like scheduling
customer support data entry and much
more Jasper can integrate with various
communication channels including phone
email messaging
and much more to customize the suit of a
specific needs of a business so it's aim
to enhance customer experience increase
efficiency and reduce costs for
businesses so if you are looking for an
alternative to charge GPD Jasper AI can
be the perfect option for you
on the other hand we also have some
other more alternatives to charge GPT
like replica Amazon legs Google but
Microsoft Bing and perplexity the future
of AI continues to change and adapt as
quickly as it started by finding
additional uses Beyond content
generation such as customer service
email optimization product
recommendation and social media posts
now at this point it's hard to judge
which chat bot is better as they are
both in their early training days charge
GPT is of course efficient at generating
and summarizing test request but bad on
the other hand can be a good option and
does a better job of answering questions
with more relevant information these
chatbots are still being trained as
users submit feedback so there may be
many changes in the coming days as well
now this is where simply learn can help
you upskill in the ever evolving field
of AI and ml our post graduation program
in Ai and ml course is designed for you
to acquire solid foundation and in-depth
knowledge on Am Machine learning
Concepts making it an excellent choice
for individuals looking into
covers a wide range of topics and
provides hands-on experience in
developing a and ml solutions from
professionals who want to upgrade their
skills and people to a career in the
field of a and ml the course features
master classes by Purdue University and
IBM experts exclusive hackathons to help
you master various skills like
statistics python supervised learning
neural networks NLP deep learning and
much more by covering tools and
techniques like numpy pandas python
sci-fi along with amazing industry
projects so what is stopping you from
building your future in AIML enroll now
host link is the description box below
now let us take a minute to hear from
our Learners who have experienced a huge
success in their careers really to keep
updating your skills on a regular basis
no matter what level you're at a
recently completed the professional
certificate program in Ai and machine
learning from Simply learn in
partnership with Purdue University the
course material was comprehensive The
Faculty was extremely experienced The
Faculty was able to adjust their
teaching style in order to cater to the
overall skill set of the class in the
rapidly evolving world of technology
it's important to keep up Skilling for
every working professional stay relevant
continue learning and with that we have
come to the end of today's session on
best alternatives to chat GPT I hope you
found this tutorial informative and
helpful if you have any further queries
regarding any of the topics out in
today's session feel free to let us know
in the comment section below and a team
of experts should be more than happy to
help resolve all your queries at the
earliest
stay tuned to the channel for more such
amazing content until next time thank
you and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here